the Joe Rogan experience I'm cool with
anything we decide I just think it
should be hip-hop dancing and we should
do it twice a year okay just wait wait
wait one other thing shoot you were
saying earlier how your body moves so I
want to know like are you flexible are
you super flexible Barry yeah sure let's
see it can you just what yeah you just
put show us on the table right now can
you do it yes like yeah you can I can do
a split you only fight genes have lycra
in there
so let me show me how to do a split
first and I'll show you if I can do a
split listen I don't want to get it a
muscle pull so I'll go down as far as I
can go with same same same here yeah
yeah you do the same well you guys just
save time and touch dicks now all right
yeah dick is about that far off the
ground and I think if you didn't have
the the I think if you didn't have jeans
on the okay the gravity would take his
dick all the way okay all right all
right that's legit yeah Bert yeah
and you go that far I launch goes yeah
further if you can
so now wait a minute yeah yeah all the
way down like you do yes
yeah okay ready Bert yes okay those
pants are not even designed for that oh
dude I gotta tell you that was really
close a lot further
this is the exact conversation we had
all month last October we got an e down
too bad look here's the deal what's the
deal I'm not going into sober October
I'm definitely charging every one of you
[ __ ] just like I did last year
one of the shittiest all-time specials
of all time would come even shittier
yeah yeah Bertie got a leg what do you
say something better
we don't saying no whatever we decide to
do I'm still going to said you did that
last year
no no no no last year he's awful and
he's gonna come back strong but he was
saying he's gonna come after us like he
did last year I think I'm drunk listen
hear me okay
I go save ya I'm not gonna not talk [ __ ]
this year interesting okay no it can't
work anymore right but that's why when I
do it it is so sad if Mickey Mantle's
not dead
Mickey's mother literally literal Mickey
Mantle is did I have the Mickey Mantle
gene what does it mean dude my dad spoke
at the memorial so bad you know I wanted
to people who died of disease and stuff
like that a lot of people and I wanted
to yell out they didn't have the Mickey
Mantle JD
I did a I did a date I don't know
recently and there was with the
promoters that you work with now and so
you work with like one promoter he's in
row what the promoters yeah yeah yeah we
all do okay keep going so I was trying
to say yeah the Mickey Mouse Oh Mickey
wonder if it's like a single guy we go
yeah when we're hanging out with your
girlfriend he's got this one
man he's got this one guy get a call I
guess I'm your promoter Bert oh yeah
tell you I heard Tom talking to other
motors and it may be proud that I'm get
promoted oh they know someone else you
would I mean you wouldn't be that
hurtful that you would be referring to
someone else's your promoter
[Music]
they they brought up the gene and
they're like I'm bingo I've done a bunch
of dates with him and I try to hang out
but no we keep all days they're like I
can't do it booze yeah they're like I
can't very few people can keep up with
my pace on the road Marc Maron or Mark
Moore normally I would say he's worried
about don't try to you wait Norman drink
Oh
what day is it nightly try I don't know
it's just it's just I mean no no no I'm
saying why did he try like why would he
try to Brooke above rookie Matsu I said
you go on your pace just be with hundred
percent there's that guy's name the
premier agreed that the surfing
challenge was too crazy right well I was
thinking it might be a fun idea
no fine now here's the thing it's like I
don't live anywhere near a [ __ ]
you're gonna be in the Sun and you're a
[ __ ] you own it you live near New York
and you live near that Long Beach but
you're gonna be on the road we're we're
two people who really dance York they
serve I'll be dancing gonna dance
I don't know
[Applause]